the reason I invest in credit card
companies is because I want some of
those profits don't let me profit from
you that's crazy I can't make 21% in the
market every
year hi there Chef wonderful here again
I thought it'd be a great time of the
year family gathering preparing food
getting together with friends and family
to talk about the year and year ahead as
well so like to get into some planning
for the new year okay I think you should
think about this a little bit the worst
thing you can do number one is push off
financial planning that's a very bad
idea you don't want to cut that out of
what you do you should plan every
quarter what am I taking in what am I
spending am I going into debt you do not
want to go into debt debt is bad cuz
most people put it on their credit cards
at 21 22 23% interest the reason I
invest in credit card companies is
because I want some of those profits
don't let me profit from you that's
crazy I can't make 21% in the market
every year but the credit card companies
do off your balances if you leave them
on over the month do not do that pay off
your credit cards so it's all about
financial planning remember I've said
this about watches too don't buy a watch
you can't afford don't go into debt for
a watch you should only buy watches you
can afford and that's part of financial
planning just throwing that out there
very simple rule on financial planning
take two pieces of paper you don't need
computer for this on one side over a
90-day period That's 3 months put all
your sources of revenue how you make
money you pay your side hustle whatever
whatever else you do to bring in cash
the other side what you spend on rent
and food and everything else what goes
out in other words what comes in what
goes out you got to make sure that what
goes out is not more than what comes in
all right that's very important now
number two this is also very important I
don't want you neglecting your
relationships because you have to build
your network friends and family are very
important but in life it's also
important to build a social and business
relationship and maintain them it's not
that hard to send someone a message
every couple of days just so they you
stay on their radar screen you don't
want to just completely go off someone's
radar screen for months and months
because then there's no bond anymore or
give them a call or go out for a drink
somewhere or meet them for a coffee
people that are important to you are
important to you for many reasons it's
good to have a social network you really
only have 15 friends most of your life
but you could have hundreds of people
you know and at least 30 that are
important to your career so think about
that that's number two never neglect
building your relationships and
maintaining them okay very very
important now something else I want you
to think about it's sort of a something
I've talked about quite a bit is sort of
underestimating importance of your first
impression you know what this means if I
walk in a room and you've never seen
seen me before what are you going to see
I have a good haircut on usually I'm
wearing a suit unless I'm chefing like I
am today and I make sure that I look
great why first impressions are
everything I'm not unshaven I'm not
unclean you know I make sure I look good
what clothes am I wearing I've talked
about this with tease because men's
skincare really matters this Dome the
Dome of Desire I don't want it sunburned
I make sure it's got SPF 20 or 30 on it
every day because I live in Florida I'm
on the boardwalk I'm walking around I
got to keep the Dome looking absolutely
gorgeous that's why it is the Dome of
Desire now if you have a dome of desire
you have to maintain it too or your skin
think about it you only have one chance
to make a first impression that's number
three on the Hit Parade hi Mr Wonderful
here if you've been watching my videos
for a while you know that te Hanley is a
longtime sponsor and it's because I
actually believe in and use their
products you know I'm a straightforward
and noons kind of guy and that's why I
love te Handley they've simplified the
whole skin care game for a guys none of
that unnecessary stuff just the
essentials you need to keep your skin
looking and feeling amazing look at me
that look
spectacular Let Me Tell You Folks a
quality skincare routine can do wonders
for your confidence and if you're just
starting out I recommend you start with
te hansley's level one system it's got
everything you need that's right a daily
face wash and exfol ating scrub an AM
moisturizer with SPF 20 yes this product
in particular is essential for the Dome
of Desire keeps the sun off it and a PM
moisturizer never used skinc care before
no worries T Hanley makes it stupidly
simple for guys in every box there's
this handy card that tells you exactly
when to use each product and how much of
it to use and in what order now I'll be
honest I used to brush off skin care but
since I started using te Handley I wish
I'd start it sooner and it's not just me
they've got over 7,000 festar reviews
from guys all over the world and because
T Handley is sponsoring today's video
they're offering my viewers a great deal
just click the first link in the
description you'll get 30% off your
first box plus a free gift don't miss
out on this amazing deal click that link
and get started today look good and feel
great that's what te handling is all
about stop comparing yourself to other
people you're not like other people I
you know I hear this all the time oh but
I'm not like him I'm not like her of
course you're different you're unique
you should focus on what makes you
unique that's number four that's so
important to actually understand who you
are and promote yourself that's the
whole idea what what are my strengths
what are my weaknesses let's focus on my
strength let's not compare myself to
some movie star or some social media
dude who
cares you're you you have to build your
own confidence up I tell this to people
all the time young and old alike look
there's always some going to be richer
than you there's always going to be
someone more successful than you there's
always going to be someone poorer or
less
successful that's how it works that's
what life is understand where you sit in
that pecking order and be proud of it
I'm never going to be the richest sky on
Earth I don't care I want to be
successful in what I do and I want to
build my businesses and help my
entrepreneurs and do what I do and build
my relationships up with everybody I
care about friends and family and
business associates the best I can
that's being the best Mr Wonderful Mr
Wonderful can be I'm not jealous of
anybody because I can't be them anyways
and guess what kitties they can't be me
either think about that sometimes they
can't be you and be proud of that
there's only one you and that's why I
want you to understand Point number four
is one of the most important don't be
jealous of other people be proud of
yourself all right number five on the
HIIT parade you have to get this in your
head it's not easy to do particularly if
you're risk inverse you have to be
willing to take risks most people never
take enough risks in their career
they're too nervous to do it
particularly when you're in your 20s you
want to take those chances cuz you can
afford to you don't have as much
financial burden on yourself usually you
don't have a house or family yet and so
you don't have a mortgage or kids you
got to feed and a wife you have to take
care of or vice versa your significant
other doesn't matter the point is you
got to take risks and you got to make
decisions of consequence that's why I
don't like people that become
Consultants they never make any
decisions of consequence that's why I
never hire Consultants after 2 years
they're tainted they've never done
anything that makes a difference to
anybody they just make recommendations
all the time nothing wrong with that
career but they never make it decision
of Consequence the only way you advance
is you take risks make decisions of
consequences learn from your mistakes
you're going to make many of them and
just keep trucking on down the road
that's how it works number six remember
this this is also very important you
never stop learning ever you never stop
learning always be educating yourself
I'm always trying to play the guitar
better be a better photographer read the
next paper on bond maturity see what's
going on in the European stock market or
the US in all the areas I pursue I want
to be learning all the time that's
absolutely crucial am I the best chef on
earth almost but I was almost room
almost means I got to learn more can
anybody beat my crep Flom no my escargo
nobody beats my escargo but could I make
a better roast beef maybe the only way
I'm going to do that is I'm going to
learn I'm going to keep working on my
chefing until I'm perfect and I'll never
get there but it's a lot of fun trying
life is about learning and friendships
and great food and great wine and a
career and all of these things I wish
the best to all of you and all my
entrepreneurs have a fantastic holiday
and a great New
Year happy holidays
everybody